so i have some fun questions to start
things off since i have a little extra
time um and i don't know if you guys
have ever thought about this but i'm
gonna throw it out there if you could
get financing to make anything you want
like any tv show any movie what would
you make and why
well i'm fortunate enough that something
that is my dream project that i do want
to get financing for to make is actually
happening right now and i can't talk
about it so i i don't know if i have an
answer for you there because it's
actually happening so
um
yeah sorry i wish i had something uh
something i i i feel like honestly it's
anything that's like adventurous
anything that is has passion and is
exciting and um tells a story that that
people need to hear which is honestly
why i love this movie so much not the
segue but um
anything that tells a story that i wish
i could have seen when i was younger you
know anything that that um is really
making an impact on the world uh you
know i think that's my answer i
definitely i definitely agree with that
um that's that's that's such a like
difficult question because like there's
there's so much that you could do with
that um but i
i would
i would want something um that that
really just like speaks to
like that gives an important message and
and and speaks to the world and um
inspires them to uh
to
i i
i i don't even know but like something
something something that's that's fun
and uh emotional and really that people
can connect to uh on a deep level um i
feel like my answer is similar to josh
like my first answer would be it's
something that i am working on it's a
script that i wrote
and i'm pitching to people and so i
don't want to
i don't want to jinx it i don't want to
put i can't say anything because
it will happen i want it to happen um
but i guess another thing that also will
happen when i put my mind to it um i
write music so i would love to get my
like my project castles
adapted into like a film adaptation i
don't know if you've seen like black as
king by beyonce or something like that
where it's like a
musical but it's not necessarily the
musical theater style something like
that to really map out the story of
the project of the eps i think
something like that would be so amazing
to create
i love that
i know that you guys are all fans of
broadway at least i think you guys are
all fans of broadway if you could go
back in time and watch any previous
broadway production uh what would you go
back and watch and why okay i have an
answer for this um so so i i there's
there's there's there's an off-broadway
production happening right now but if i
could go back it's not on broadway
anymore i would love to see a little
shop of horrors when it was on broadway
because um i love that musical so much
and um
i i also am a huge wicked fan so if i
could go back and see the original cast
um i was also very lucky to be able to
work with uh norbert leobutz and
michelle federer uh on the movie who are
amazing uh but like if i could go back
and see that that would be that would be
really really cool um if i can go back
and watch dream girls i'd be done with
life like oh my gosh i cuz i love the
movie
so to like to be able to see it and like
see it live that would be so amazing
because it's one of my favorites and
then also is it still running i don't
know hamilton i would love to see
hamilton at like
live that would be so fun to see on
broadway
those are all great answers uh you know
it's funny i i'm like blanking on other
than like i saw wicked recently for the
first time and it was very obvious that
the cast have been doing it for a minute
and so i was sort of like
yeah i wish i had i could go back and
see it with the original cast but um
another one is is i was actually in new
york um for like my first time ever
pretty much
right when dear evan hansen was
premiering and um i had no idea what it
was i hadn't heard the soundtrack at all
and all my friends are going and they're
like do you want us to get you a ticket
we can get you a ticket and i was like
dear evan hansen i was like what is that
i don't even know what that is and i
wanted to hang out with this girl so i
was like you know what it's okay we're
just gonna go get pizza and like you
guys enjoy the show and and now i'm like
looking back like i listen to that
soundtrack like every day for a year and
i'm like dude how did you not go see ben
platt
as he premiered evan hansen um
fortunately i was able to see andrew
barth feldman um later who is now one of
my best friends um
but you know i think that i always go
back and i'm like why why would you
waste a night in new york and not go see
that so i guess that would be my answer
that's a like that's a that's a life
lesson though i think that in the future
when you get invited to something uh you
will be like i am going to the broadway
i will support the pizza
the people probably be there
exactly uh listen first congrats on the
movie i know there's going to be a lot
of people that really really love this
for soon to be fans for each of you what
do you think would surprise people to
learn about the actual making of the
movie
i think there were so many things about
the movie that were like
super
interesting to like know how it happened
behind the scenes um i think
just a lot of the scenes were actually
filmed like on location so we were
actually in a theater actually in a
rehearsal space actually in the middle
of times square so that was super
interesting to see um how they like
shut down the areas just for our film
and we were like just basically in new
york so it made us feel like we were
actually there i thought that was really
really cool and really cool to
experience um just being on actual sets
because i've never done anything
like at that level before yeah yeah i
was you i i was gonna say exactly that i
was gonna say um like how i think it
would be surprising
to people like how much we filmed like
at the actual places because a lot of a
lot of movies like um like build like
sets to make it look like the place and
those are all really good but it was
something else entirely for like the
filming experience to actually go and be
at those places and experience
the the entire
like worlds it it was just it was just
so so cool yeah i feel like i feel like
what comes up for me other than that
that was actually my first answer um is
uh
people would be surprised that this is
ruby woods first film and tv experience
and this is tim federly's first
directing experience you know i think i
think when you see their performances
when you watch the film like it's sort
of hard to believe but it's almost a
proof of concept in my opinion that that
ruby wood stepped into nate and just
shot for the stars and went beyond them
in the same way that nate you know is
like i know that i don't have any
experience doing this but i'm going to
go to new york and i'm going to make my
dreams happen and shoot for the stars i
think it's really cool how he's like a
living walking embodiment of that so i
think honestly people are just going to
be surprised by how much talent this
whole cast has aria included and
emphasized you know and i think um
i i just think they're going to be blown
away by by the personality and the joy
brought by each each actor uh which of
you which of your friends and family
were the most excited that you were
working with lisa kudrow and are any of
you guys like friends super fans
um i i i have a i have a good answer for
this so uh one of my i definitely love
friends it's an it's an incredible show
it's so funny and just so genius and um
one so i one of my aunts um
in real life not aunt heidi uh
is is a friend's super fan like she's
seen all the seasons multiple times and
um
it she she just like absolutely lost it
when i told her that i was working with
lisa kudrow and i i actually um sent her
a video
of me and lisa together and and i was
like uh it was it was it was
like after after i had met lisa and
gotten to know her i was like hey so my
real aunt is is like a really big fan of
yours and um maybe we could make a video
for her and lisa was like totally so i i
made uh my aunt her name's lacey my aunt
lacey a video of me and lisa and she
just she just freaked out it was so good
it was so amazing or any are any of you
guys uh friends super fans
absolutely absolutely i mean i love
friends i've seen like every episode i'm
pretty sure so i'm a huge fan i think my
sister
one of my sisters is a specifically lisa
kudrow fan like specifically and she's
also like very similar to her in a lot
of ways i literally think they could
play like relatives in a movie um
but but yeah when i told her she was
freaking out she's like is there any way
to get on set and i was like i don't
know because you know the coven
protocols but um but yeah so i i
definitely am a fan and my family is a
fan so it was a pretty neat pretty neat
thing
and me and my parents like we both love
or both all three of us love friends um
i think when i remember when we were on
the zoom me
um and ruby when we first had got the
job to like meet as
the
leads or whatever we um when he was
telling us okay so joshua bassett is in
this film and i flipped um and then he
said
lisa kudrow or have you guys seen
friends we're like of course um phoebe
from fr
excuse me the best character on front
like phoebe heard like comedy very
similar to lisa kudrow in real life i
feel like that was just i was super
duper excited because working with her
was very fun and i know her from a lot
of her other stuff as well so my sisters
knew her too that was just really fun to
work with her that note i gotta wrap i'm
just gonna say congrats on the movie for
real and i hope it's a huge hit and good
luck with the rest of your speed dating
thank you
you